今日は俺の名前はてディグダはじめ入れマスターとここ数年行ってないですよひさしぶ
りっ
デュエルマスターズやろうと思ったわけですよまあお前達には分からないだろうなと
言えるばっさんですけどどんなものか俺買って説明しての伸びで髪型セットすると
髪の毛が立たないわけですよ
悠遊カードとはまた違ってね俺がたして小4小5ぐらいの時に流行ってたカードゲーム
です
結構ね俺のアレやってる人がいるなと僕の事務所の社員さんが一人やってて
ルーツとして負けられないなと思ったわけですよまあ必要だと思ったものはまずカード
なんだよ
だからまあそれはカードを集めることでしたマーカーとがないと始まらないと国を守っ
たんでだから僕はね近くにあるコンビニで言ってるデュエルマスターズカード全部買っ
てきました
全部で3回も勝っても効果にかかるともっとバーンと一回全部買ってでも彼はないです
このカッター中でデッキを作ってそれでも釣っております勝つために方がと言う楽しむ
ためにやるんでね
なればいいでしょ奪えず僕は久しぶりにでよりますとするからねウールをほとんど覚え
てない周囲は何が強いかもわからない
とりあえず開けてみようと思っているまあこの中から俺のジュエリスト人生が始まる
わけ誰かが全裸スターズや確かで御所買ったんですよこの水自然に光やミノーな誤植た
ラディッツようなが自由に作れる3で俺はねどうするかた
を得ず当たるほど便国のバーニングスを登録居るぞゴルシク
8買ったなぁこちらです自由の祭典ドラゴン魂フェイスこれが20パックです
ウルトラできてみました価値観がレクサス行ってこれが目立つな症
そう victory
ねあと3段変形入会オールスターすると流体っていうのはこちらないんですよ新しい来
て全然わからないけど俺が10レースと総理などが力を芽生えさせるのは間違い
届け俺の心の中の流会ヴェーダのよはい
相次ぎです最後はこちらで過去にはあったんだ服ごと買ってきましたいう海外キング代
なんかめっちゃいるーですよ解禁ぐらい金が g king 大 r といろいろ選ん
でちょっと分けバック
とりあえずこちらがあったら買ってきました入会がいいんですルーズ海外銀河
者数が来ていこうと思います一番好きですから行こうこちらだんっ
暴れろはが大事にパワー
グルーたべきと言いました全62種類別の行くぞ
たっぽいけど前にすごいから俺の夢のカード
ぴぎゃリプレイカードキドさんちょっとてて5人の院内イヌハッカ
5人のインナーいいな作家
プリーグでキュッキュッってるッ
目指せのこと大事現れ平日のドロー
あダメだったら楽しいのカードあるウェア
もう一つまなっぺ今一人一花園と講談と静的デトロイトテクノすっ
ライトニングスーパータック
まず現れろ煉獄の軽い
だめだ伝説の紙を俺のことですカードん
終わりですありがとうございます次はこれいきましょう3台編言友会オールスターズ
1泊300円というまあそので山分期待できるかな
いくぜよ闇火をせ
dope ドラ棒
なにこれ
これ店じゃねぇめっちゃミスってるよカードしついてる
会でっこにこれぞにこれなにこれ
うっ
ちょっと不これカードなのなにこれ3
入会カードあこれ3 d てこういうことにコレなにこれすごいあが世界乾物
今井分のカードってくらいバカでかく一体んだよホンダ c 税10%会
ねえカードが出たもんだだから高いのか乗っ
6月と持ってきたツリーで入会年血流
馬力で目がまっちょんまたに浮かんできますライトニング supercard
超天星では the world 方なんです対応をご加護があらんことを
一色のせいりゅうろセールのワールパンツでブッチかっこいいんだけどね成長累積回も
ジャンクるーか謎ですよ
煉獄から集いし前節のカード龍海
あれかぶったまさかの債務炙りですこれまずいんじゃ
態度次こちらです[ __ ]もいない
冬の祭典ドラゴンダースいいえ俺の下僕をアナバレよ
はが大事に召喚どんなもんだろ c フェス
ルータ
ええええ
22歳ですこれはドライバーしか出ないからねちょっと楽しいですねスゴイ
これじゃないでしょ今日は共感ないキラキラのカードが出ましたうつけ悪いっクワトロ
あーマゼラ純あなたの中な
寒流アナカバー龍海なんとかだったかなとか
麺とか中央でっネット振りだす超次元ゾーンというのだがハートへ本当はサイキック
クリーチャーがおけるせた
ラルクアンジェルダル管制官が強いな人類桐生木プラ塩や今お前らいよいよラストこの
中に入っているカードで俺の人生雪も
外銀ががとても当たりにくいという話を聞きました多分平均6000円が参加しす
カード1枚でルーターに飛ぶカード全部裏返しでおいてどんどんめくっていきます
フェンスで外銀があってます行くぞ木属性の
数多いよ
今のところレアカードチターべき英雄街編水
いい出だしでいい出だしですこういう感じでちょっときってことですね
いやがウロボロ成果の翼& lomb
bau でからと9
レーサーリフォーム区こちらのベアを2
次の青年でさえパターンは含まれるてっとニュースで答えるいうジャンルよ
の人が反らせバスがそ器具
それよりば前回値ふと max エナジースペルビア max の時だっ賞与日々今日
の大事な心解けた言おうとしてると言えないで言います楽しいの記憶月の光の力を満ち
たというのはこの2枚ラン行くぞ
いいかいい
be sure
ます
e 7